a circle a curved surface and another
circle this is a cylinder a right
circular cylinder to be precise every
cylinder has a central axis which passes
through the Centers of the two circles
the areas of the two circles are equal
that's because the cylinder we consider
has a uniform cross-section this tells
us that the radii of the two circles
will be equal in a right circular
cylinder the distance between the two
centres of the circles is its height
let's call it h so how do we find the
total surface area of the cylinder it
will be the sum of areas of the two
circles and the area of the curved
surface as the radius is R the area of
each circle will be PI R squared so the
sum of the areas of both the circles
will be PI R squared plus PI R squared
but what is the area of the curved
surface this is interesting the curved
surface when opened up will look like a
rectangle and what will be the length
and the breadth of this rectangle the
breadth is easy it will be the height of
the cylinder but what about the length
yes the length of the rectangle will be
the circumference of the circle it will
be 2 pi R it was easy all we did was
open this curved surface up anyway these
two together add up to 2 PI R squared
and the area of this rectangle will be 2
pi RH that's it this is the total
surface area of a cylinder with radius
of the base R and height H as 2 pi R is
common to both the terms we can write it
as 2 PI R times R plus h that's the
total surface area what is this blue
part then it's called the curved surface
area of the cylinder 2 PI R 8
and finally we come to the volume of a
cylinder it equals the area of its base
times its height as the base is circular
its area will be PI R squared and its
height is H that's the volume of a
cylinder PI R squared H you don't have
to memorize any of this you can easily
derive the total surface area and for
the volume you just need to know that it
is the area of its base or its cross
section times its height